[Music]
you acted as a child didn't you I yes I
did not that successfully but I did I
didn't mean nothing I mean I just I
wasn't I wasn't very good I was I would
getting nervous I did I had a small
little stint on the guiding light mm-hmm
soap opera mm-hmm
when I was about 15 and I just really
was bad I was really I was I played the
son of the chief of surgery they brought
me in for like two days it was like a
Christmas vacation episode and the guy I
had to do a scene where I'm playing
chess with my dad and I didn't play
chess I didn't I didn't know it at all
and so the actor before we did the scene
they do it really quick you know they
just like a whole hour show in a day so
in the rehearsal he said okay I'm gonna
move my pawn and take your queen and
then you know you can move your Bishop
and that'll be the scene and then we'll
go into the scene and and they called
action and I just froze up and I freaked
out and I just started moving pieces did
you did you have a line or and I had one
thought I had one line I had to say good
night Eve and it really was hard I
really was hard yeah my sister still
makes fun of me for how I said it really
yeah because you know sometimes they say
having just one line is harder than
having a lot of lines because you can
overthink it I think having any lines
for me would have been hard and so yeah
and I tried to make it maybe like it was
part of the characters you know like he
he has panic attacks when he says good
night even they didn't work that
backstory into
so and then and then the next year they
brought the character back but they
brought a different actor in oh that's
yeah apparently when he'd gone to
college and he came back and he was
about six inches taller he had blonde
hair and was Gentile changing time okay
the movie the watch a lot of very very
funny idea of a lot of very funny stuff
in the movie you play a Costco manager
yes yes I play a Costco manager and
which was fun because we actually got to
shoot in a Costco which was like a dream
come true this giant you know it was
amazing everything was fake but it was
still we were in this place and you know
and and it was great cuz Costco let us
use their name and and and you know the
logo and everything without charging us
any money or having to do any
endorsements which is great you know
just shows you what a quality company
Costco
you know I mean know some super stores
you know the consumers just faceless but
a Costco every customers family kind of
sounds like you're endorsing Costco no
comment I'm not they don't need me to
endorse them I mean everybody knows
Costco is your one-stop shop
[Applause]
[Music]
and they match any price point I mean if
you're a millionaire like yourself or
just a guy like Andy you're gonna work
with your budget yeah now you've won me
over sounds fantastic you've obviously
been bought off with gallons of mustard
it's a really good place Costco I hope I
get in on this whatever you're getting I
hope they give me a taste